Hi, and welcome to Exploratory Data Analysis, or EDA. In the
last few months, I learned about R, a programming language, and EDA
with the help of my friends from Facebook. And in this course,
I'll teach you how to use R to conduct Exploratory Data Analysis.
>> EDA is one part of the
larger process of collecting, learning from and acting
on data. In this course, I'll share
my advice about working with data and visualizations.
>> By the end of this course,
you should feel confident when exploring new data
sets to uncover meaningful patterns. In the last lesson,
I'll walk you through an analysis of the
diamond market with an eye toward building predictive models.
>> We're excited to teach this course, and to show you
how EDA can be used to answer questions with data. But before
we dig in to EDA, let's talk about data. Data is
ubiquitous. You can find information about
hurricanes, forest fires and state finances
on websites like data.gov. Social networking sites like
Facebook, where we work. Collect petabytes of data everyday.
And some people have started tracking their own personal
data using calendars, mobile apps, and physical activity trackers.
>> There is so much data out there in
the world, and so little of it has been explored.
For example, I was poking around on Google trends
the other day and here's what I found. I searched
for the word chicken, because I had read a
news article that morning about chicken food poisoning and salmonella.
And when I search for the word, Google Trends gave
me this graph. This graph shows the interest in searching
for the word chicken over time. In reality, it's counting
how many times we see chicken in any newspaper headlines
in a given month. So from 2005 to 2013, we
can see that occurrences of chicken has been increasing. Now,
I didn't want to stop my search there, so I decided
to enter two more generic word to see what I could find.
So I added the word music and I added the word movies.
And then I got this graph. Now when you look at this
graph, tell me some things that you notice. You can talk
about anything interesting that you find in this graph, or you might
compare the first graph to this one and write some things that
you find. Now, keep in mind there is no right or wrong
answer here, I just want to get you thinking about data.